shake shack has opened for trading the  opening trade was forty seven dollars a  share up a hundred twenty-three percent  from its IPO price of 21 dollars which  on its own was raised from the initial  range of seventeen to nineteen dollars  shake shack currently at 4902 and  earlier today maybe just three minutes  ago in fact it hit a high of 52 49 so  52-49 is a high-water mark here for  shake shack on its first day of trading  the company raised 105 million dollars  in this initial public offering will  continue to monitor all this Eric but  I'm sad to say I won't be able to  celebrate with a shake shack seneca's  already have one earlier this week a  host girl why does having one shake  shack and are you from having another no  no I've set myself a limit you can't  have shake shack more than once a week  once a week is already plenty